>> Pete: JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO IN THE AFTERMATH OF A
NERVE AGENT ATTACK, THE
TARGET OF A FORMER RUSSIAN
SPY IN THE U.K. THIS IS
PRACTICALLY ALL WE HEARD
FROM DEMOCRATS AND CRITICS
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LISTEN.
>> WHY ON EARTH DOES DONALD
TRUMP NOT CALL OUT THE
RUSSIANS, THEY ARE ATTACKING
OUR ALLIES.
THEY ARE ATTACKING OUR
ALLIES AND HE IS LOOKING THE
OTHER WAY.
THAT IS A DISGRACE.
>> MAX BOOT, ONE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S FIERCEST
CRITICS.
THE PRESIDENT DID THIS
INSTEAD.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
IS EXPELLING 60 RUSSIAN
DIPLOMATS IN RESPONSE TO THE
POISONING OF A FORMER
RUSSIAN DOUBLE AGENT AND HIS
DAUGHTER IN ENGLAND.
>> Pete: THAT WASN'T ENOUGH.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALSO BEEN
RELENTLESS IN MAKING THIS
DEMAND.
>> PUTIN WILL COOPERATE FOR
TWO REASONS.
ONE IS IT'S BECAUSE IT'S IN
HIS INTEREST OR BECAUSE YOU
ARE TAKING TOUGH ACTIONS
AGAINST HIM LIKE GOING AFTER
THE OLIGARCHS ON WHOM HE IS
SO RELIANT WHICH TRUMP WON'T
DO.
>> Pete: SOMEONE WAS
LISTENING.
SO WHAT DID PRESIDENT TRUMP
DO TODAY?
>> WE DO HAVE SOME BREAKING
NEWS TO BRING YOU RIGHT NOW.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
IMPOSING NEW SANCTIONS ON
RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS AND
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
>> Pete: OH, CNN.
DON'T EXPECT TO STOP HEARING
THIS FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
CRITICS.
>> THERE IS STILL THE
QUESTION WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS NOT TAKEN A MORE
AGGRESSIVE PUBLIC STANCE
AGAINST VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
PUBLICLY SAID ANYTHING.
>> Pete: THERE ARE ALWAYS
STILL QUESTIONS.
WILL PRESIDENT TRUMP EVER
GET CREDIT FOR CRACKING DOWN
HARDER ON RUSSIA THAN
PRESIDENT OBAMA EVER DID?
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
TO STEVEN COHEN PROFESSOR OF
RUSSIAN STUDIES AT NEW YORK
UNIVERSITY.
MR. PROFESSOR, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE, I APPRECIATE IT
I WILL ASK YOU THAT
QUESTION.
WILL THIS PRESIDENT EVER GET
CREDIT FOR CRACKING DOWN ON
RUSSIA?
>> WELL, THEY KEEP TELLING
HIM TO GET TOUGHER AND THEY
KEEP MOVING THE GOAL POST
AND THE END ZONE IS WAR.
>> Pete: HIS CRITICS ARE
SAYING GET TOUGHER.
WHEN HE DOES GET TOUGH THEY
SAY THAT'S NOT ENOUGH AND
ULTIMATELY YOU ARE SAYING IF
YOU WENT THAT TOUGH IT LEADS
US SOMEWHERE?
>> WELL, I MEAN, IF YOU WANT
TO ASK ME WHETHER TRUMP HAS
BEEN TOUGHER THAN OBAMA ON
RUSSIA, IF WE QUANTITY PHI
IT, THE ANSWER IS PROBABLY
YES, HE HAS EXPELLED MORE
DIPLOMATS.
HE HAS LEVELED MORE
SANCTIONS.
>> Pete: HE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPEL DEMOCRATS IF HE COULD.
>> HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU AND I, HAVE YOU GOT A
FAMILY I'M GUESSING.
>> Pete: UM-HUH.
>> WE ARE IN DANGER.
I WOULD SAY THE GRAVEST
DANGER IN REGARD TO RUSSIA
SINCE THE MISSILE CRISIS.
WE ARE IN A NEW COLD WAR.
IT'S NOT A JOKE.
IT'S MUCH MORE DANGEROUS
THAN THE LAST.
WE'RE IN EYEBALL TO EYEBALL
MILITARY CONFRONTATION,
UKRAINE, BALTICS AND SYRIA.
>> Pete: SURE.
SENT WEAPONS TO UKRAINE AS
WELL.
>> STOP AND THINK, I'M OLDER
THAN YOU SO I REMEMBER THIS
VIVIDLY.
THROUGHOUT MY LIFETIME,
EVERY AMERICAN PRESIDENT,
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN, HAS
BEEN EMPOWERED TO DEAL WITH
THE LEADER IN THE KREMLIN TO
KEEP US OUT OF WAR AND
PREVENT NUCLEAR WAR.
>> Pete: MAINTAIN A
RELATIONSHIP?
>> RIGHT.
>> RIGHT
>> BYGHT
>> BY TT
>> BY THE WAY THE THREE
PRESIDENTS WHO DID THAT THE
MOST REPUBLICANS EISENHOWER,
NIXON AND REAGAN.
TRUMP SENSES WE'RE IN GRAVE
DANGER WITH RUSSIA.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT HE WANTS TO TALK TO PUTIN
WITH INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM
AND NUCLEAR ARMS RACE.
IF HE PICKS UP THE PHONE AND
CALLS AND SAYS LET'S TALK,
HIS CRITICS WILL SAY IT'S
TREASON.
SO, WELL, IT'S NOT FUNNY.
>> NO WE ARE IN DANGER AND
WE HAVE ALWAYS LOOKED TO THE
PRESIDENT.
I DIDN'T VOTE FOR TRUMP.
I OPPOSED SOME OF HIS
POLICIES.
BUT HIS STATEMENT THAT IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO COOPERATE WITH
RUSSIA IS THE TRUTH.
AND EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD
SUPPORT THAT AND NOT ATTACK
HIM FOR TRYING TO DO IT
BECAUSE HE IS OUR SAFETY
WALL BETWEEN DISASTER.
>> Pete: YOU ARE SAYING IT'S
A SMART MOVE PERSONALLY
TOUGHER.
WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT RIGHT
THERE UNFORTUNATELY.
IN THESE MOMENTS YOU NEED
WISDOM AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE NEED TO NAVIGATE